these signatures given at a historic
summit in Qatar as capital Doha are a
milestone on Afghanistan's road to peace
after almost 20 years of war but that
road was always going to be rocky under
the deal
the Afghan government will release
thousands of Taliban prisoners ahead of
talks between Afghans but Afghanistan's
president Ashraf Ghani said his
government never agreed to that
and it wasn't for the u.s. to decide H
no no commitment has been made for the
release of 5,000 prisoners we have
repeatedly shared this issue clearly
with the US envoy as Al Michaels add and
other officials this is the legitimate
right and self-determination of the
people of Afghanistan a request has been
made and it can be part of the
negotiation but it cannot be a
precondition madam f1 stands for many
Afghans the hope of an end to the
violence is tempered by fears for their
country's future if the u.s. leaves
Afghanistan we Afghans are worried about
a return to the brutal situation that
the Taliban will start their attacks
again so we call on the Taliban to sign
the peace deal with the Afghan
government as soon as possible
women and girls especially suffered
severe repression under Taliban rule
Kabul veterinarian Tahar RSI is worried
about the threat to women's progress if
the group regained strength who talks
with the government I don't feel very
optimistic because I don't know who will
come to power if there's peace with the
Taliban looking at their history I feel
less hopeful that I'll be able to
continue my work if there's peace with
the Taliban it's now a waiting game to
see how talks between different Afghan
groups play out following Saturday's
deal likewise I people here hope they
won't have to pay for peace with their
freedom and we're joined now from Kabul
by FAL Zia CUFI a member of the Afghan
parliament in one of the few women who
took part in the negotiations aimed at
bringing an end to decades of conflict
ms Kofi you took part in these
negotiations I understand are you
satisfied with the outcome well people
in Afghanistan including myself we're
cautiously optimistic I'm saying
cautiously optimistic because first of
all it is a beginning of an important
process where the Afghan Islamic
Republic and then the Taliban have to
really set in few days we are hoping as
it's agreed mention in the Taliban and
the United States agreement we have to
set in few days and discuss those issues
that people of Afghanistan are worried
about discuss about women's rights Civic
rights the future of the government
where everyone will feel included and
then in the meantime we we are we are
optimistic because this is the beginning
of a big process but we are cautious
because there has not really been major
steps by Taliban to build trust and to
demonstrate that they are that they have
changed that they will not come back
as they were ruling Afghanistan during
1996 that they are committed to the
demands of people of Afghanistan and
also we're cautious because there is
also not a tide of understand Islamic
Republic delegation has to be really
inclusive we have to start preparation
for you know kind of making that team of
negotiation yes I just wanted to ask you
there's a very important point that in
this story right now President Ashraf
Ghani says his government has not
pledged to release thousands of Taliban
prisoners even though that's part of the
deal that the Americans apparently have
made with the Taliban does that put this
deal in jeopardy this deal initially was
that there was less involvement from
Islamic Republic Afghans including the
government and the political community
to be part of this to make sure that
every step is agreed upon and then it
becomes practical and it becomes you
know something that could be applied
well and applicable so therefore I think
the first challenge now is five up to
five thousand Taliban prisoners
I think logistically also to verify
whether the third the five thousand
Taliban you know the ones who actually
not should not go back to the
battlefield should not use their you
know weapons again against the people of
Afghanistan how do you verify that how
do you you know kind of make the
distinction to release the Taliban that
have not been really involved in major
crime including suicide bombing so I
think this is a challenge logistical II
but also politically because the loss of
Anniston are very clear I mean yes
probably inside Afghanistan we have
different views and and whose views are
just only under Islamic Republic when it
comes to Taliban we have to really
respect the laws of Afghanistan and for
that I think this is a this is a
commitment that needs a lot of time a
lot of discussion and a lot of there is
a lot of issues about it okay so many
issues remain of posi a coupie member of
the Afghan parliament thank you so much
for talking with us this morning